bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans cette nouvelle vidéo où nous allons
parler d'un phénomène cosmique qui
devrait arriver dans le futur du mca
pour être honnête ça fait un moment que
je souhaite revenir sur le film de
eternalz car il est plutôt singulier 1
comparé aux autres films du mc eu
puisque il apporte bas des éternels les
héros les plus anciens qu'on ait connu
dans le mc eu et notamment pas aussi les
célestes qui apporte beaucoup de
mystères et pas mal de questions et
voilà maintenant avec la sortie vod du
film j'ai pu le revoir et du coup bah je
me sens prêt aujourd'hui à vous en
reparler en détails et en maîtrisant le
sujet on va dire donc il est temps de re
proposer de belles théories donc sans
plus attendre comment sont si je vous
disais qu'il existe un problème
concernant les célestes me croyez vous
comme déclaré dans le film les célestes
font partie des premières entités à
peupler l'univers grâce à ces derniers
il y a pu y avoir la naissance des
galaxies la naissance des premiers
soleils et donc la naissance de la vie
en elle-même et caetera et c'est grâce à
eux et à riches aiment l'expliquent très
bien la vie peut prospérer et trouve
donc un équilibre car à chaque milliard
d'années des célestes naissent à partir
d'un embryon implémenté dans une planète
planète qui prendra la fonction duff
d'incubateurs et quand le céleste sera
prête à naître la planète et la vie
présente dessus s'éteindra mais le
céleste qui en sortira permettra de
créer de nouvelles galaxies et donc par
conséquent amené de la vie voilà une vie
s'arrête pour qu'une autre commence
c'est un cycle infini de créations et de
destructions
mais vous ne remarquez pas un problème
là dedans cet équilibre n'en est pas un
en fait le film des éternels nous
démontre la pertinence d'un équilibre
pour que l'univers puisse avancer à
raychem nous dit que l'univers est un
échange constant d'énergie les éternels
existe justement pour contrer les
déviants les déviants retire la vie
alors que les éternels la protège il y à
un équilibre mais
concernant les célestes il est où l'
équilibre ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que d'accord les célestes
permettent de réguler la vie et à chaque
milliard d'années de nouveaux céleste
naissent pour parfaire cet équilibre
mais néanmoins aller où l'opposition des
célestes arish m explique à cercy
comment ils doivent naître mais il
n'explique pas comment hummer et si ils
doivent mourir et c'est là le problème
si nous suivons la logique d'art echems
plus nous avançons plus il y adeux
céleste arish m est désigné comme le
premier céleste et ce dernier est encore
présent aujourd'hui pour faire prospérer
la vie et faire naître d'autres céleste
donc vous l'aurez compris si nous
continuons comme ça il y aura un
surpeuplement de céleste dans l'univers
au début du film des éternels cerci
faisait un cours à ses élèves dédié à
l'existence et l'importance des super
prédateur si nous suivons la définition
les super prédateurs sont des prédateurs
qui une fois à l'âge adulte se retrouve
au sommet de la chaîne alimentaire c'est
à dire qu'il n'ya rien au dessus d'eux
pour les menacer ces derniers sont très
importants car elles permettent de
réguler les populations exemple tout
simple les végétaux se nourrissent d'eau
de nutriments et de la lumière du soleil
grâce à la photosynthèse ces derniers
sont mangés par les caselles gazelles
qui sont elles mêmes mangés par les
lions qui au sommet de la chaîne sont
considérés comme des super prédateur si
nous retirons le super prédateur un
déséquilibre va naître car nous ferons
face un surpeuplement de gazelle et par
conséquent les végétaux seront impactés
en conséquence et donc l'environnement
et la vie en général
vous commencez à comprendre où je veux
en venir cette métaphore du super
prédateur a mené dans le film est lourde
de sens pour mieux appréhender l'oeuvre
est l'avenir du mc car là où nous
pourrions penser que les célestes sont
des super prédateur qui permettent les
équilibres de la vie et de l'univers eh
bien ce ne serait pas le cas puisque un
superprédateur d'après la définition
afin d'amener un certain équilibre
possède un faible taux de reproduction
et c'est là le hic les célestes se
multiplient mais ne meurt pas donc par
conséquent plus il y adeux céleste plus
de galaxies sont créés ce qui symbolise
en soi l'expansion de l'univers
sauf que vous savez tous ce qu'il va se
passer au bout d'un moment c'est le big
crunch l'univers devient tellement dense
suite à l'expansion qu'il s'effondre sur
lui même le voilà le déséquilibre est
tout ce que je vous dis là peuvent vous
sembler farfelue mais c'est une
thématique qui existe réellement dans
l'est si eternalz s'inspire clairement
de la réalité alternative
9997 la terre x dans cette réalité les
célestes afin de se reproduire imprègne
les planètes d'un embryon qui après
maturation devient un nouveau céleste
avec le temps ils surent peupleront
l'univers et cela engendrera le big
crunch l'effondrement de l'univers et
comme je vous expliquais dans de
précédentes vidéos l'univers de marvel
fonctionne en cycle c'est à dire que
l'univers se reforme avec l'effondrement
du précédent avec un nouveau big bang
une nouvelle expansion etc etc mais du
coup comment contrer le déséquilibres
générés par l'existence des célestes et
comment du coup gérer un possible futur
surpeuplement il est vrai que nous avons
déjà fait face à la mort de céleste dans
le mc eu comme thiam août qui s'est
sacrifié pour permettre à la terre de
prospérer ou encore no where qui est une
tête de celle est coupée et désormais
habitée mais en vrai cela reste des caps
plutôt exceptionnel en réalité il faut
un super prédateur capable de menacer et
réguler l'existence des célestes et bien
il en existe un et pas n'importe lequel
vous savez de qui je vais parler et les
grand temps d'annoncer l'arrivée du
destructeur de monde l'une des entités
les plus connus de l'univers marvel il
s'agit bien évidemment de galactus
[Musique]
unique survivant de l'effondrement de
l'univers précédent gallan un
explorateur originaire de la
civilisation de ta a été approché par la
sentience du multivers une entité
suprême incarnant le sixième cosmos et
qui a fait survivre gallan au big crunch
en le faisant renaître en tant que
galactus le dévoreur de mondes désigné
comme une véritable menace de par sa
nature de dévoreur de mondes galactus
est en réalité une entité neutre il
n'est ni bon ni mauvais ils exécutent
simplement la mission que la nature lui
a ordonné il est en réalité hyper
important pour l'univers car il permet
justement de créer l'équilibré avec
notamment les célestes à cause de sa
principale particularité sa fin cosmic
galactus a constamment besoin d'énergie
pouvant être obtenu seulement via les
planètes capable d'accueillir la vie
comme expliqué auparavant avec le
concept de super prédateur galactus
permet de contrebalancer la mission des
célestes en dévorant des planètes et par
conséquent étant donné que les célestes
imprègne les planètes d'un embryon et
bien cela signifie que galactus permet
d'équilibrer le peuplement des célestes
à travers l'univers si galactus n'est
pas alors comme dans une chaîne
alimentaire un déséquilibre secret les
célestes sur peupleront l'univers et
étant donné que nous sommes dans une
échelle cosmique et bien cela signifie
également la fin et l'effondrement de
l'univers mais du coup comment intégrer
galactus omc eh bien j'ai une
possibilité
une théorie à vos proches déjà de par sa
nature d'être le plus ancien de
l'univers car à l'origine galactus
normalement vient de l'univers précédent
peut-être que ce sera réadapté dans le
mc eu mais en tout cas c'est l'être le
plus ancien de l'univers cela
signifierait donc qu'il existe déjà dans
l'uem singh mais du coup pourquoi n'en
at on jamais entendu parler eh bien il
se pourrait que galactus ne soit pas
encore réveillé et en état de dévorer
des mondes et c'est là que les éternels
pourrait intervenir mais pour ça il faut
que nous retournions rapidement sur
l'origine story de galactus une fois
approchée par la sentience du multivers
gallan maintenant devenu galactus à
l'aube de la naissance d'une nouvelle
univers est en hibernation dans un
vaisseau en réalité cela correspond au
temps où galactus est en train de se
construire avant de véritablement naître
dans les comics galactus se fera même
approché par un watchers découvrant la
véritable nature du protagoniste en
hibernation et hésitant sur ce il doit
laisser sa vie ou non le watchers va
malencontreusement le réveiller avant de
s'échapper et galactus qui n'est pas
encore prêt va se construire une armure
capable d'accueillir et maîtriser son
pouvoirs cosmiques puis va transformer
son vaisseau en un incubateur lui
permettant de se reposer et d'hiberner
le temps d'arriver à maturation et
d'épouser son véritable rôle et c'est là
pour moi que nous pouvons relier
l'origine story à l'univers du mcs cette
étape d'hibernation et de maturation dur
pendant des milliards d'années
littéralement ce qui veut dire dans le
mc eu qu'il est largement possible que
galactus ne soit pas encore
véritablement né il se peut qu'il soit
encore dans son incubateur en train de
dériver quelque part dans l'espace
maintenant par rapport aux éternels le
film nous a fait comprendre qu'à riches
m était désigné comme une menace et pour
cause les éternels sont des marionnettes
et des pions pour les célestes il existe
seulement pour contrer les déviants et
faire prospérer la vie afin que les
célestes puisse naître à la fin de leur
mission ils sont risette mentalement ils
n'ont aucun souvenir et les célestes
leur font même croire qu'ils viennent
d'une autre planète qui n'existe même
pas toutes leurs origines sont basées
sur des mensonges et seuls quelques élus
complètement dévoués à leur créateur
connaissent la vérité donc à la fin du
film nous sommes clairement dans une
ambiance de rébellion star fox
accompagnés de tena macquarie ou encore
druide n'ont que pour seul solution
d'aller retrouver les autres éternels
éparpillés à travers l'univers pour leur
raconter la vérité est qu'ils arrêtent
d'agir comme les pantins des célestes et
c'est malheureusement la seule chose
qu'ils puissent faire pourquoi car ils
ne peuvent rien faire contre les
célestes et on le remarque également
quant à rich m reviens vers la terre
cerci souhaite vivre son histoire
d'amour avec dane fast hausse a envie de
mener sa petite vie tranquille en
compagnie de son compagnon et de son
enfant kingod souhaite reprendre sa vie
d'avant en tant que star du cinéma mais
ils ne le peuvent pas car arish m en a
décidé autrement et ce qui va en
découler c'est qu'ils seront à très
fortes chances vez est mentalement une
fois car echems aura consulté les
souvenirs de ces derniers donc voilà il
n'y a pas de libre arbitre les éternels
sont contraints d'obéir à are et shem et
aux autres céleste ou sinon bah ils
devront subir leur courroux et seront
reset mentalement et le souci c'est
qu'ils ne peuvent absolument rien faire
contre eux on parle quand même d'entités
ultra cosmique gigantesque capable de
créer des galaxies c'est là que galactus
interviendrait dans une obsession
d'anéantir leurs créateurs ultime les
éternels pourrait avoir pour solution de
trouver l'incubateur de galactus et le
réveiller pour qu'ils puissent contrer
les célestes et équilibrée l'univers
néanmoins ne sachant pas spécialement la
véritable nature de l'être cosmique et
cela pourrait s'expliquer du fait que
les éternels sont manipulés par les
célestes dans le sens où comme je vous
disais au début harish m explique à
cercy l'importance des célestes et de
leur naissance mais en aucun cas de leur
mort et du déséquilibre qu'il crée en se
multipliant eh bien les éternels dans un
premier lieu serait satisfait d'avoir
enfin trouvé une entité capable de se
mesurer au céleste et d'abolir l'emprise
totale d'harish m sur ces derniers mais
serez vite rattrapé par la véritable
nature de galactus de la même manière
que sylvie a engendré l'arrivée
prochaine de quang le conquérant et de
la guerre multi vercel à cause de sa
rancune personnelle les éternels
engendrerait l'arrivée prochaine du
dévoreur de mondes une entité qu'ils
seront incapables d'arrêter et qui
pourrait mener à une unification total
des héros que l'on connaît pour défendre
leurs vies d'ailleurs galactus est
toujours accompagnée d euros soit des
personnes chargées de trouver des
planètes pour galactus et devant
transmettre le message que le dévoreur
de mondes est en train d'arriver étant
donné que les célestes ont eux aussi
leurs soldats soient les éternels on
retrouve encore une fois une sorte d'
équilibre où les éternels pourrait
potentiellement affronter les héros de
galactus tandis que le dévoreur de
mondes et les célestes sont en train de
s'opposer enfin il y un dernier élément
qui me semblent intéressants à partager
si galactus il y a il est clair que nos
chers avengers ne resterons pas les bras
croisés et justement c'est ça qui est
pertinent galactus est le nemesis des
célestes arrêt scheme qui doit revenir
jugé la terre pourrait épargner cette
dernière car c'est justement sur cette
planète que la solution pour contrer
galactus s'y trouvent en analysant les
souvenirs de cercy et des autres
éternels en voyant que l'humanité a
réussi à vaincre des entités comme
thanos art echems détecterait le
potentiel des terriens pour s'opposer
aux dévoreur de mondes qui est une
menace pour les célestes mais à la fois
aussi pour l'humanité a vous de me dire
ce que vous en pensez
enfin voila je tenais à faire cette
vidéo et je suis très content de l'avoir
fait il ya réellement des éléments
intéressants concernant l'impact des
éternels et des célestes pour l'avenir
du mc eu et cela pourrait faire pourquoi
pas l'objet de prochaines vidéos j'ai
d'ailleurs une petite idée concernant
une possible liaison entre l'arrivée de
gore dans thor love and thunder et le
film des éternels mais bon nous aurons
l'occasion d'en reparler pour de vrai
l'arrivée de galactus et ipad mais je
pense que nous avons encore le temps
déjà car cela pourrait clairement se
faire dans un sequel d'ci eternalz mais
bon on a clairement je pense le temps on
est on est vraiment pas encore là pour
un eternalz 2 mais également le dévoreur
de mondes a clairement les toffes pour
devenir l'ennemi ultime d'une phase du
marvel cinématiques universe et étant
donné que kang a déjà été teasé par
l'arrivée de la série law qui
est notamment entre man 3 eh bien il va
peut-être falloir attendre quand même
mais bon tout ça devrait arriver un jour
ou l'autre n'oubliez pas le petit pouce
bleus à laisser un petit commentaire
concernant galactus comment vous pensez
qu'il pourrait arriver dans le mc eu
tout ce genre de choses en vrai c'est
hyper intéressant de parler de galactus
et de son arrivée dans la même cellule
le sujet est clairement intéressant
voilà n'hésitez pas non plus et surtout
à vous abonner à la chaîne car
franchement 2022 à y avoir plein de
belles vidéos il ya plein de choses à
faire et puis bah écoutez le lay and
rare soit avec vous cet argot rock allez
ciao tout le monde
[Musique]